Spanish textbooks were so ahead of their
time in PC culture if you look at any
[ __ ] old Spanish textbook from high
school there was always like a white guy
a black eye an asian girl and then
always a guy in a wheelchair you
couldn't flip three pages without seeing
a [ __ ] guy in a wheelchair they were
always down with the like paraplegic I
feel like part of it was because they
one of the things that they tried to
drive home drive home was I always
remember say yesterday relieved that I
think that means wheelchair see God they
ruled us that's what it is
see ya they ruthless oh my god dude we
would listen to this [ __ ] audio tapes
and we'd be they would say it they'd be
like wheelchair like a white chick would
say wheelchair and then the guy would
come on and he'd be like sigue there
with us and what what our class didn't
realize and I always realized I hated
that they [ __ ] class didn't pay
attention to this [ __ ] but they would
you were only supposed to say it after
the first time and then the guy would
say it just to remind you see yeah they
ruin us and then it would go on to the
next one it would be like baseball and
then you would have to say baseball but
everyone thought you had to say the
[ __ ] thing twice so it will be like
see ya there Louie thus see they ro eat
us see the Ruth us and then everyone be
like see ya and they'd be like baseball
I don't really or Wyatt and I would
always be like no you only [ __ ] say
it once
dude I would laugh so hard at that [ __ ]
I loved it by the way how much is that
[ __ ] guy whoever did all those audio
books that guy sounds like he walking
straight up got up in the morning put on
a nice button-down shirt [ __ ] no tie
it's open at the top because he's and
then a [ __ ] blazer and that's it no
pants or underwear and he just says see
ya Louie this and his dick is [ __ ]
medium-sized and he's in the recording
booth and he doesn't give a [ __ ] and
he's got a [ __ ] uh would he call my
tie drinking a mai tai with flip-flops
you